لا بد من التاكيد على اننا دوله من دول
العالم الثالث التي استعمرها الغرب ولم
يتركها تستقل الا شكليا فجعلها تابعه له
حتى في الاكسجين الذي تتنفسه
[موسيقى]
فوجود هذا الكيان السرطاني على حدودنا
واحتلال لارضنا وتدريس لمقدساتنا كان اخطر
شيء يواجهه على الاطلاق لذلك سعى
الاستعمار لجعلنا دوله وظيفيه وظيفتها
الرئيسيه هي حمايه هذا الكلى وجعلوا يتوسع
اكثر واكثر في جسد الامه
[موسيقى]
ورد على لسان الزميل ان نحن دوله مستقله
شكليا وهذا الكلام مرفوض نحن دوله لنا
سياده ولنا قوات مسلحه ونحن موجودين مش
لحمايه اسرائيل احنا دوله لنا سياده
[موسيقى]
قلت ان الاستعمار ارادنا ذلك وهذا ليس
معنى انه انا اقر بذلك هكذا اراد الاعداء
ونحن نواجه ذلك من خلال
اذا كلامك هيك انا بعتذر منك انا غلط
معناته
[موسيقى]